il nous faudra prendre nous le savons
des mesures d'urgence pour répondre aux
besoins du pays et de votre quotidien
une loi pour le pouvoir d'achat et pour
que le travail paie mieux des premières
décisions pour aller vers le plein
emploi des choix forts sur l'énergie et
le climat des mesures d'urgence pour
notre santé qu'il s'agisse de notre
hôpital ou de l'épidémie tous ces
progrès ne saurait être financé ni par
plus d'impôts ni par plus de dettes
budgétaires et écologique c'est pourquoi
notre pays plus que jamais a besoin de
réformes ambitieuses pour continuer de
créer plus de richesse plus de travail
et innover davantage
ça c'est la clarté la responsabilité
ensuite il faudra bâtir comme je
l'expliquais des compromis d
enrichissement des amendements mais le
faire en toute transparence à ciel
ouvert si je puis dire dans une volonté
d'union et d'action pour la nation qui
concerne toutes les forces politiques à
commencer par la majorité présidentielle
mais toutes les autres mais aussi les
forces vives les partenaires sociaux les
élus les associations nous tous pour
cela il faudra clarifier dans les
prochains jours la part de
responsabilité et de coopération que les
différentes formations de l'assemblée
nationale sont prêtes à prendre
entrer dans une coalition de
gouvernement et d'action s'engager à
voter simplement certains textes notre
budget lesquels pour avancer utilement
il revient maintenant aux groupes
politiques de dire en toute transparence
jusqu'où ils sont prêts à aller